สวัสดีค่ะครูนิกสวัสดีครับครูเรียมสวัสดี
นักเรียนทุกคนด้วยนะครับสวัสดีค่ะนัก
เรียนอืครูนิก
หะครูนิกอยู่ที่ไหนคะอยู่ที่บ้านอยู่ที่
บ้านครับแต่ว่าวันนี้เนี่ยจะไม่ได้อยู่ใน
ห้องทำงานที่เคยถ่ายวีดีโอเพราะว่าคุณนิก
ตื่นสายแล้วยังไม่ได้กินกาแฟก็เลยก็เลย
ปกติเนี่ยจะชงกาแฟกินแล้วก็สอนไปด้วยทำ
วีดีโอไปด้วยใช่ไหมครับแต่ครั้งนี้ก็เลย
เออไหนๆก็ยังไม่ได้ทำกาแฟก็เลยทำไปด้วย
แล้วก็คุยไปด้วยะกันอ๋อได้เลยครูนิจะแบบ
ทำกาแฟมาให้เรียนใช่มยเออได้ทำแล้วแต่โยน
ไปให้สาดสาดใส่
คอมพิวเตอร์ใช่ใช่จะขอบคุณมากที่แบบมี
บาริสต้ามาวันนี้คือคุณนี่ก็ติดกาแฟใช้คำ
ว่าติดกาแฟก็ได้แหละคือตอนนี้เหมือนมัน
ต้องกินทุกวันแต่มันไม่ได้กินเพื่อให้ตัว
เองตื่นน่ะคือมันกินเพื่อให้ได้กลิ่นน่ะ
เพราะว่าเหมือนกับปกติเนี่ยเวลาคุณนิกไป
ซื้อกาแฟคุณนิกก็จะเหมือนกับไม่รู้ว่าครู
เรียมเคยสังเกตมยอ่ะอย่างอันเนี้ยอันนี้
จะเป็นกาแฟที่ครูนิกจะทำวันนี้ใช่มเป็น
เมล็ดมยคะครูนิกเป็นเมล็ดใช่ของจะเป็น
เมล็ดแล้วก็เอามันจะมีเครื่องบดที่เอาบด
ใส่ก่อนอ๋อเเคยเห็นที่เา้าหมุนน่ะหมุนกืด
ๆๆๆคือตอนเนี้ยตอนนี้อยู่ในห้องครัวพอดี
มันก็เลยหาอะไรได้ง่ายหมดเลยใช่อยากกิน
ขนมค่ะครูนิกตอนเนี้ยขนมหรอไม่เป็นไรพูด
เล่น
ขนมก็มีคืออันเนี้ยอันเนี้ยครับจะเป็น
เครื่องบดกาแฟที่ครูนิกใช้มันก็เหมือนกับ
ใส่กาแฟที่เป็นเม็ดอ่ะเข้าไปแล้วก็เสียบ
ปลั๊กแล้วมันก็จะบด
อ๋ออือ๋อเรียมเข้าใจว่าเป็นเครื่องบทแบบ
เรียมเคยเห็นแบบที่ต้องเอามือหมุน
น่ะอ๋อถ้าเป็นแบบนั้นเนี่ยอืแบบนั้นน่ะ
คุณนิจำไม่ได้ว่าเคยเห็นมั้ยอืแต่ก็ก็คิด
ว่าน่าจะเคยเห็นมั้งแต่ไม่ได้เห็นบ่อยอื
อ๋ออันนี้ก็ใช้ไฟฟ้ากดปุ่ม
ปื๊ดใช่ๆแล้วอันเนี้ยสมมุติไม่รู้ว่าครู
เรียมจะสังเกตเห็นหรือเปล่านะคือกาแฟอ่ะ
ถ้าเป็นแบบเม็ดอันเนี้ยอันเนี้ยคือมันจะ
เป็นแบบเม็ดใช่มอูบ
ใช่เป็นเม็ดกาแฟใช่สีดำมากเลยอื
คือเวลาครูนิกเลือกกาแฟอ่ะเจะเอาเป็นเม็ด
เพราะครูนิกคิดว่าถ้ากินกาแฟที่มันบดแบบ
สดๆก่อนที่จะทำกาแฟอ่ะมันหอมกว่าอือแล้ว
ก็ทุกครั้งเวลาคุณนิไปซื้อกาแฟอ่ะมันจะมี
เนี่ยไม่รู้ว่าเห็นมยตรงเนี้ยครับมันจะ
เป็นเหมือนเป็นกลม
ๆมันเป็นมีให้อากาศเข้าออกเหรอคะครูนิก็
เป็นให้อากาศเข้าออกด้วยเพราะว่ามันไม่
ให้ชื้นแล้วทีนี้เนี่ยไอ้ตรงนี้แหละเวลา
ครูนิกไปซื้อกาแฟอ่ะครูนิกก็จะเหมือนกับ
บีบถุงนิดนึงให้มันมีกลิ่นออกมาแล้วเราจะ
ได้รู้ว่าเราชอบกลิ่นนี้ไหว้าวเตรียม
เพิ่งรู้เรียมแบบเรียมไม่ได้มีไม่ได้มี
ความรู้เกี่ยวกับกาแฟเลยแต่เรียมก็แบบไป
ดูเพจที่เขาเคทำร้านกาแฟแล้วเคก็เลยพูด
เรื่องกาแฟิมก็เลยได้ยินครั้งแรกว่า
เฮ้ยมันมีรายละเอียดเยอะมากเกี่ยวกับ
กาแฟไม่ใช่แค่ว่าแบบตากใส่แก้วใส่น้ำร้อน
มันไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่ก็มันจริงๆอ่ะคุ
นี้ิก็ไม่ได้รู้คือไม่ได้เรียนหรือรู้แบบ
เยอะคือทุกอย่างที่รู้เี่ก็คือจาก
ประสบการณ์ตัวเองที่เคยไปซื้อกาแฟมาบ่อยๆ
แล้วบางทีก็เห็นใน Google บ้างว่าเขาบอก
ว่าต้องซื้อกาแฟที่เมล็ดกาแฟมาจากประเทศ
นี้ประเทศนี้แถบนี้จะดีอ๋อแล้วครูนิกแนะ
นำจากประเทศไหนที่ครูนิคิดว่าแบบหอมแล้ว
ก็ชอบมากคือถ้าถ้าเกิดง่ายๆง่านะง่ายๆเลย
เนี่ยก็ของประเทศอินโดก็คืออินโดนีเซีย
อืม
อ๋อใช่คืออินโดนีเซียเนี่ยจะหาง่ายถ้าเรา
อยู่ประเทศไทยหรือแถบเอเชียเพราะมันอยู่
ใกล้ๆ
อ๋ออืเรียมเคยไปชิมอ่ะไปชิมที่ร้านกาแฟนะ
เดมรู้สึกว่าเรมชอบกาแฟของ
เอธิโอเปียเอธิโอเปียก็ดีคือเอาง่ายๆครับ
ว่ากาแฟเนี่ยกาแฟที่เขาบอกว่ามันดีส่วน
ใหญ่เนี่ยจะอยู่ในประเทศที่มันร้อนแล้วก็
ชื้นประเทศไทยด้วยใช่มั้ยประเทศไทยก็มีนะ
ประเทศไทยก็ถ้าจำไม่ผิดก็มีเหมือนกันแต่
คุณนิกจำไม่ได้ว่าภาคไม่ภาคเหนือนะก็ภาค
ใต้อื
อืใช่มีภาคเหนือเต็มเคยไปภาคเหนือเพราะ
ว่าต้นกาแฟเนี่ยเขาจะปลูกแบบใต้ต้นไม้ต้น
อื่นครับเออแล้วก็
แบบเออดีๆเหมือนกับภาคใต้ที่คุณนิกรู้ก็
คือชุมพรชุมพรเจะมีเค้าเรียกว่าอะไรกาแฟ
ขี้ชะมดอ่ะอือันนั้นก็แพงแต่ครูนิกไม่เคย
กินนะเออไม่เคยกินก็แบบคิดอยู่เหมือนกัน
ว่าแบบจะลองดีมยแต่หลายคนบอกว่าดีมันหอม
อืว้าวแต่มันแพงไงถ้าราคาคือที่ไทยเหมือน
ขาย 1 แก้วอ่ะแก้วเล็กด้วยนะ 500 บาท
โห
อืแต่คุณนิก็เข้าใจแหละเพราะมันก็ชื่อมัน
บอกว่ากาแฟขี้ชะมดเนี่ยกว่าชะมดเนี่ยจะ
กินเอาออกมาเนี่ยเออกว่าจะกินอะไรแล้วออก
มาเนี่ยมันก็ไม่ง่ายมันจะขี้ออกมาใช่กว่า
มันจะแบบอิออกมาละเอออ่ะ 500
บาทออุ๊ยครูณีครูนิกยังไม่ได้ดื่มกาแฟเลย
เช้านี้ยังครับแบบงกาแฟก่อนเลยได้จะต้อง
บอกก่อนว่าเพราะตอนเอยู่ในห้องครัวเนี่ย
มันอาจจะมีเสียงดังแบบเพราะที่บ้านมัน
เหมือนมีนาฬิกาคุณปู่แล้วมันจะดังทุก 15
นาทีอ๋อนาฬิกาคุณปู่ก็คือแบบอย่างเงี้ย
ที่เก่าๆตึ๊งๆตึงตึงใช่ไอ้ตัวเนี้ยไอ้ตัว
เนี้ยออมันก็จะดังทุก 15 นาทีแต่ว่าได้
เลยเมื่อก่อนที่ไม่ค่อยได้ยินเพราะว่า
อยู่ในห้องทำงานแล้วประตูมันปิดอ๋อครูนิ
เราคุยกันตั้งแต่กี่โมง
นะเราคุยกันตั้งแต่แต่เวลาของครูนิกนะคือ
95 นอ๋อ
95 นนะเพราะว่าเราอ่ะไม่ได้กินกาครูนิก
ยังไม่ได้กินกาแฟเราก็เลยไม่ได้คุยเกี่ยว
กับวันที่กันเลยใช่ใช่เดี๋ยวเรียมจะบอกนะ
คะทุกคนวันนี้ที่ประเทศครูนิกเป็นวันอะไร
อ่ะ
อ่าวันพุครับอ๋อวันพุธใช่ครูนิกชงไปก่อน
นะคะวันพุเมทองไป้ก่อนที่อ่ะจำวันที่ไม่
ได้แล้วที
นี้วันพุธที่ 26  26 ค่ะเดือน
ตุลาคมใช่ปีพ.ศ
2565 แล้วก็ค.ศ
2022 นะคะทุกคนใช่อืโอเคอ่ะพนี้ต้องต้ม
ร้อนมั้ยคะอะไรนะต้องต้มน้ำร้อนมั้ยคะ
จริงๆก็ไม่ต้องนะครับเพราะว่าเครื่องอ่ะ
มันใส่น้ำปกติไปได้แล้วพอกดให้มันชงเนี่ย
มันก็จะไปจัดการของมันเองอ๋อเป็นเครื่อง
ชงกาแฟใช่เป็นเครื่องชงกาแฟก็คือมันจะไม่
ใช่ว่าแบบเป็นกาต้มน้ำร้อนกาต้มน้ำร้อน
เนี่ยอันเนี้ยกาต้มน้ำร้อนใช่ไม่ต้องครับ
อืมก็จริงๆคือที่บ้านครูนิกเนี่ยจะบอก
ก่อนว่าที่บ้านคุณนิก็มันจะมีเครื่องทำ
กาแฟ 2 อันถ้าอย่างแรกเนี่ยก็คือที่คนไทย
จะเห็นบ่อยๆก็คืออันนี้เนาฬิกาดังละออไม่
ไม่ค่อยได้ยินค่ะโอเคคืออันเนี้ยครับที่
คนไทยเห็นบ่อยตามร้านกาแฟที่มันมีเหมือน
บาซ่าทำเอสเปรสโซ่อะไรพวกเนี้ยอืมแต่
เหมือนที่อเมริกาครับหรือต่างประเทศอ่ะเา
จะมีไีตัวนี้ด้วยเนี่ยอันนั้นคือเครื่อง
อะไรคะอันนั้นก็เป็นเครื่องทำกาแฟเหมือน
กันแต่ว่าจะเป็นแค่กาแฟดำ
อ๋อแต่เดี๋ยวคุณนิกเอาให้ดูคือมันจะเป็น
แบบนี้ครับคือตัวเครื่องกาแฟเนี่ยมันจะมี
ไอ้ตัวหม้อเนี่ยอืคือจะใช้ว่ามันเป็น
เหมือนดริฟก็ได้ที่คนไทยชอบพูดกันก็คือ
เราจะเอากาแฟที่บดแล้วเนี่ยเอาไว้ข้างบน
แล้วมันก็จะมีที่กรองพอน้ำมันร้อนเนี่ย
มันก็จะใส่เข้าไปที่กรองแล้วมันก็จะหยดลง
มาตรงนี้หยดลงมาใช่แล้วก็จะเป็นกาแฟ
เดี๋ยวครูนิกจะทำให้ดูก็อันนี้ใส่มเล็ก
กาแฟเป็นในนี้แล้วเนาะเดี๋ยวครูนิกจะบดก็
อันเนี้ยครับก่อนบดมันก็จะเป็นอย่างนี้
ที่เราเป็นเม็ดๆใช่มั้ยนะเป็นเมล็ดโอ้โห
มีบาริต้ามาทำกาแฟให้ดูนะคะวัน
นี้เนี่ยนะเนี่ยคุณนิคือก็กดตรงนี้ไปแล้ว
มันก็จะ
บดอ๋อเยครับคุณนิกอ่ะครูนิกจะชอบเขย่า
เพื่อให้ว่าครูนิกกลัวว่าแบบมันบดไม่
ละเอียดอืเขย่าแล้วก็กดอีกครั้งนึงใช่
บางทีคุณนิจะชอบแกล้งแฟนเวลาแฟนคุยอะไร
ที่ไม่อยากฟังแล้วชงกาแฟอยู่คุณนิก็จะ
แบบพูดอะไรนะไม่ได้ยิน
อือืแบบนี้นี่เองเค้าจะมาดูคลิปเราหรือ
เปล่าคะเค้าก็จะรู้ว่า
อ้อบอกอยู่เพราะว่าเพราะว่าคุณนิอตั้ง
YouTube ในทีวีแล้วเวลาเอยากดูทีวีอ่ะใน
YouTube เค้าก็จะเห็นว่าเนี่ยอ๋อช่องนี้
ช่องนี้อื
[เพลง]
ออก็อันนี้นะครับเดี๋ยวจะให้ดูว่าพอมัน
อันเนี้ยคือหลังจากที่บดแล้วเห็นมะมัน
เป็นผงแบบนี้เลยผงใช่สับนมิกลายเป็นผงใช่
ก็คือเราบดละเอียดแบบนี้แล้วที่ครูนิกใส่
ครูนิกก็คือจะเอาแป๊บนึงเอาไอ้เนี้ยครับ
ที่เราบดเนี่ยใส่ในตัว
นี้เป็นกระดาษใช่มั้ยคะเป็นกระดาษใช่ครับ
ก็คือเหมือนกับเป็นที่กรองคนไทยก็น่าจะ
เรียกว่าที่กรองกาแฟเนาะแผ่นแผ่นกรองคือ
เราเนี่ยจะกินกาแฟแต่เราไม่อยากกินกาก
กาแฟก็คือกากที่เป็นเนี่ยมาจากมล็ดแบเ
อื
ถ้าเกิดแบบจากเม็ดใช่มยเม็ดแล้วก็มาบดบด
แล้วมันจะเป็นกากมันจะเป็นชิ้นใหญ่ๆอยู่
แต่ถ้าเกิดผงเนี่ยจะเป็นแบบเล็กๆเล็กๆมาก
ๆใช่ก็คือบางทีบางคนก็เหมือนกับถ้าเป็นผง
อ่ะบางคนก็จะคิดว่ามันกินได้แต่คือถ้ามัน
ถ้าแบบอย่างเงี้ยครับคือเราชงกาแฟเสร็จ
แล้วเนี่ยอะไรที่มันเหลือที่มันเป็นกากด
ส่วนใหญ่ถ้าเป็นกากๆเนี่ยเราก็จะไม่กิน
หรอกเออครูนิกเอากากกาแฟไปใช้อะไรมยครู
นิกทิ้งจริงหรอไม่เอามาแบบขัดหน้าขัดตัว
ไม่ใช่คือคุณนิกเคยลองนะแล้วคุณนิกรู้สึก
ว่ามันมันคูณนิกไม่ชอบเพราะมันเจ็บหรอมัน
ไม่ได้
เจ็บคือพอทำเสร็จแล้วอ่ะผิวมันแห้งมาก
สำหรับครูนิกนะอือืคือครูนิกเนี่ยเป็นคน
ขี้เกียจทาครีมก็เลยไม่ชอบอ๋อใช่เพราะว่า
แบบเวลาขัดผิวขัดหน้าก็ต้องทาลีนใช่ๆขี้
เกียจก็อันนี้นะเดี๋ยจะถอดเครื่องมาอคนี้
เนี่ยก็คือเครื่องอัน
นี้คุณนิก็จะใส่อีที่กรองเนี่ยเข้าไปใน
นี้
อ้านี่บ้านหรือร้าน
กาแฟจริงๆแล้วแอบเปิดร้านกาแฟออแต่ต้อง
แบบไปแบบไวทนะคะไปแบบส่วนตัวนะคะนักเรียน
เดี๋ยวครูนิกจะเอาน้ำแป๊บนึงได้เลยก็
อันเนี้ยครับมันยังไม่มีน้ำคุนี้ิก็จะเอา
น้ำเนี่ยใส่เข้าไปคือที่ใส่น้ำเนี่ยไม่
ได้ใส่เข้าไปตัวกาแฟเลยนะใส่ไปในเครื่องอ
เพราะว่า
อันเนี้ยอ่ะเดี๋ยวจะให้ดูอีกว่าสมมุติ
อันเนี้ยครับเห็นไหว่ากาแฟเนี่ยที่เราบด
เมื่อกี้มันอยู่ตรงนี้ใช่น้ำเติมตรงไหนคะ
ตรงข้างๆอ๋อข้างๆใช่แล้วพอมันเดือดนะครับ
พอน้ำมันเดือดมันร้อนเนี่ยมันก็จะไปเข้า
ไปในตัวนี้แล้วก็ออกมาเป็นกาแฟ
อ๋อเหมือนที่ครูนิกบอกว่าต้องเป็นกาฟกแฟ
ดำเท่านั้นเครื่องนี้ใช่เพราะว่ามันมัน
เหมือนมันมันมันจะผสมกับนมอะไรไม่ได้
เพราะว่าเครื่องมันทำแค่ให้เป็นกาแฟดำหยด
ลงมา
ในในเหยือกอันเนี้ยครับ
อ้าโหนี่แบบเค้าแบบเป็นแบบคนกินกาแฟจริงๆ
อ่ะใช่คือคนที่เนี่กินกาแฟกันแบบเยอะ
เหมือนกันคือคุนิเนี่ยจริจังปติเนี่ยคุณ
นิกจะกินกาแฟแป๊บ
นึงคุณนิจะกินกาแฟประมาณวันละ 3 ถึง 4
แก้วอยู่แล้วอคุณนิดื่มน้ำเปล่ากับกาแฟ
อันไหนดื่มบ่อยกว่า
กันจริงๆพอๆกันนะ
ออนะครูนิดก็เสียงปัครูครูเรียมได้ยินได้
ยินใช่
มั้ยไม่ได้ยินค่ะไม่หมายถึงได้ยินเสียง
ครูนิกมั้ยอ๋อได้ยินแบบเกก
ถ้าอยู่ไกลๆอะไรอย่าเงี้ยโอเคได้ครับก็ออ
เสียบลักแล้วไปแล้วที่คูนิกทำก็คือกดเปิด
เครูเรียมน่าจะเห็นไฟอันนี้อ๋อเห็นค่ะไฟ
สีเขียวใช่คือเครื่องเนี้ยมันก็ดีที่เลือ
เลือกได้ว่าจะเอาแบบปกติหรือจะเอาแบบเข้ม
ูนิก็จะชอบกินแบบเข้มจริงหรอเลือกที่
เครื่องหรอเรียมคิดคิดว่ามันเป็นที่แบบ
มล็ดที่เราเอาไปบ่นคืออันนั้นด้วยแต่ก็
เดี๋ยวเดี๋ยวครูนิกจะอธิบายให้ฟังจะพูด
ให้ฟังคืออันเนี้ยครับมันก็เริ่มทำงานละ
ก็ปล่อยไปให้มันจัดการอื
ก็คือตัวกาแฟอ่ะครับเมล็ดเนี่ยมันก็จะมี
ให้เลือกใช่มว่าเราจะเอาเป็นขั้วอ่อนขั้ว
กลางขั่วเข้มอืมใช่อืแต่ทีนี้เนี่ยครูนิก
เนี่ยจะชอบกินขั่ว
เข้มอือเรียมเรียมหยิบขึ้นมาดูเลยว่าอัน
ที่เรียมซื้อมาลองชิมนี่คือ
อะไรอ๋อนี่มันจะมีแบบเบอ์อะไรอย่าเงี้ย
ไม่รู้นะคนที่ไม่มีความรู้เรื่องกาแฟอ่ะ
แล้วก็เมไปซื้ออันนี้มาอ่ะมันเป็นซองเล็ก
เรียมก็เลยเอามาลองกินธรรมดาเรียมกิน
โกโก้อ๋อเรมดูในทีวีเห็นอันนี้เรมก็เลย
แบบเฮ้ยเ้าบอกว่าหอมมากก็เลย
แบบซื้อมาครั้งถ้าคุณนิกแบบรีบๆคุณนิกก็
มีที่บ้านก็มีเหมือนกันเป็นแบบกาแฟสำเร็จ
รูปกาแฟสำเร็จรูปก็เหมือนกับแค่ใส่น้ำ
ร้อนกินได้เลยใช่อันนี้เข้าแบบเป็นอันนี้
เรียกขั่วเข้มมยคุณนิกใช่ถ้าแบบนั้นครับ
คือคั่วเข้มเหมือนอย่างูมิเนี่ยก็เป็นขั่
เข้มใช่อออันถ้าเกิดแบบประมาณเบอร์เบอร์ 4
เบอร์ 1 อันนี้น่าจะเป็นแบบขั้วอ่อน 1
เนี่ยจะอ่อนใช่แล้วก็ 3 ก็คือขั้วกลาง 3
กลางใช่ออโอเคบางที่ก็จะใช้เป็นเหมือนกับ
บางที่จะไม่ใช่ 1-5 บางที่อาจจะเป็น 1-6
อก็มีเหือใช่แต่อันนั้นเขาก็จะเป็นเหมือน
แบบเคก็คิดว่าเลข 6 เป็นมันง่ายกว่าอ่ะก็
แล้วแต่แต่คือส่วนใหญ่ครับเจะเรียกว่า
อ่อนกลางเข้มแค่นี้อืทีนี้เนี่ยคูนิอ่ะ
ชอบกินกาแฟแบบเข้มๆก็
พัเข้มแล้วในเครื่องเนี้ยครับเครื่องกาแฟ
เนี่ยก็เข้มอีกให้มันเข้มอีกเพราะว่า
เหมือนเวลาเราอัจเหมือนอย่างครูเรียมชง
โกโก้แก้วสมมุติสมมุติแก้วเท่านี้อือฮึ
ใส่ช้อนเดียวไม่พอใช่โกโก้เข้มเอาเพิ่ม
อีก 3 ช้อนแต่น้ำเท่าเดิมแบบเนี้ยครูนิก
ชอบอ๋อออใช่ๆๆแล้วเครื่องเครื่องทำกาแฟ
ของครูนิกเนี่ยมันใช้เวลานานมยจริงๆแล้ว
หลังจากใส่ของทุกอย่างเข้าไปแล้วเนี่ย
ประมาณประมาณ 3-4 นาทีก็โอเคละอเดี๋ยวจะ
ให้ให้ดูเหมือนอย่างตอนนี้นะครับตอนนี้
เนี่ยมันก็เนี่ยเห็นมยว่าไม่รู้ว่าเห็นก็
เยอะแล้วนะไม่ประมาณนี้ได้คือครุณนิกอ่ะ
จะใส่น้ำเข้าไปอ่ะครับน้ำที่ครุณนิกใส่
มันจะได้ประมาณ 6 แก้วโ 6 แก้วแต่คิดว่า
เป็น 6 แก้วที่มันไม่ได้เข้มถ้าเข้มมันก็
จะน้อยลงหน่อยนึงใช่อ๋ออ้อก็คือครุนี้กด
เลือกเข้มๆก็คือน้ำมันจะน้อยลงใช่น้ำมัน
จะน้อยเข้าใจะเข้าใจก็เหมือนอย่างตอนเ
ครับตอนนี้คิดว่าคิดว่าใกล้ะเพราะว่ากาแฟ
มันขึ้นมาจนถึงประมาณ 4 แก้วก็คิดว่าน่า
จะโอเคีแบ่งมาทางนี้บ้างได้เดี๋ยวสาดไป
ให้ครับสาดมาให้ไม่ใช่ส่งสงนนะคะสงกรานต์
เก็ไม่ได้สาดกาแฟนะคะบาริสต้าทำไมทำแบบ
นี้คะเดี๋ยวคนิกเอาแก้วก่อ
อืแบบคุณนิกทำให้เรียมอยากกินกาแฟไปด้วย
อ่ะเวลาไทยประมาณ 21:00 ครึ่งอ่ะทุกคนเย
คิก็กินกาแฟตอนกลางคืนบ่อยคืออย่างที่บอก
ว่าคุณนิกอ่ะกินกาแฟให้มันได้กลิ่นกิน
กาแฟเพื่อร่างกาย
เพราะเมื่อก่อนคูณนิดไม่ได้ไม่ได้เข้า
ห้องน้ำบ่อยคือไม่ได้ขี้บ่อยก็เลยต้องกิน
กาแฟให้มันช่วยู
สิอ๋อเป็นกาแฟสำเร็จรูปใช่กาแฟสำเร็จรูป
ค่ะไม่ต้องไปกดบดจื๊ดไม่ต้องคือแก้วใส่
น้ำร้ออีกอย่างนึงที่ครูนิกเนี่ยจะไม่จะ
เลือกกิกินกาแฟสำเร็จรูปเป็นอันสุดท้าย
เนี่ยเพราะว่าคุณนิครู้สึกว่ามันไม่ใช่
กาแฟจริงๆมันเหมือนแบบถ้าแบบเนี้ยเราเห็น
ว่าเป็นกาแฟ
100% แต่ถ้าสำเร็จรูปอ่ะมันเหมือนมันมี
อะไรผสมอีกที่มันไม่ใช่กาแฟอย่าง
เดียวครูนิมได้กินก่อนครูนิกแล้วอ่ะกลับ
ไปครูนิอ่ะกดติดไปแล้วแต่น้ำมันยังหยดครู
นิกก็เลยกลัวว่ามันรอก่อนค่ะรอได้
ค่ะวันนี้เรียมก็ได้ดื่มกาแฟแล้วครูนี้ก็
จะดื่มกาแฟเดี๋ยวเราจะอัดคลิปวดีโออีก
ประมาณ 4-5 คลิปนะคะจะเห็นเสื้อแบบเนี้ย
เนี่ยมันก็จะได้แบบเนี้ยอ้าวมาแล้วอืแล้ว
คุณนี้ก็จะกินแค่
นั้นเรียบร้อย
ว้าวอันนี้ก็จะอยู่ได้ประมาณทั้งวัน
ทั้งวันนะมาค่ะคุณอิกชนแก้วแล้วก็จะได้
แบบปิดคลิปละโอเคได้
[เพลง]
ครับไปกินกาแฟแล้วไว้คุยกันใหม่ครั้งต่อ
ไปใช่คุยกันใหม่ในคลิปหน้านะคะทุกคนใช่
ครับโอเคสวัสดีครับสวัสดี
ค่ะ